I make about $80,000 a year I have about
$85,000 in Consumer Debt spread out
between a car payment a personal loan
and some credit cards I started working
with this company um that is you know
supposed to negotiate with these credit
card companies and the personal loan
company to help uh bring the balance
down these debt settlement relief
companies yes yes exactly coming to the
horrible realization that this was a bad
idea MH and to the point where most of
these accounts are defaulted um or you
know not going to work with me
personally um so I don't really know
where to go from there in the baby steps
so we're selling the truck first off
that's what I'm doing because a guy
who's making 80,000 probably shouldn't
have a car that's more than half of his
annual income that's kind of just a rule
of thumb that we go by around here and I
mean yours is just a little above but
considering your debt